Dimitri first of all uh congratulations
something nice game it was it was it was
a gift it was a blunt the rose so it's
not even a pawn it's a Central Pawn it's
a central point yeah this moment when
you saw the move Knight G E5 what was
your reaction I I saw it in advance so
he cannot do that yeah yeah and when he
made it what well unfortunately Doug
blonde that he also there's some big
problem for really senior players he's
not dead singer than me it's it's uh
blunders because everything else is
so so understandable yeah and you're
talking about the blunders I remember
that game against uh Maxim loogie you
play that move G3 Bishop E3 game over
but then immediately you showed no King
F2 was making a draw yeah showing on the
board well well it wasn't it was a drop
position but it wasn't that simple I
looked over it could be some trips and
well I played badly he had played me
very nicely I had a great opening at
some point and then uh he uh we got
equal position because I played a couple
of bad moves and um a little bit more
and then he started playing for win and
he out played me very brilliantly and
definitely he deserved to win this game
yeah he was winning before one move
before he was in position so but you
came back with black pieces well
yesterday I played also America the
great game can be in the book
into his variation but they didn't play
correctly so yes yeah and after he took
on D4 you executed the attack perfectly
uh it was some well first of all he had
the move which was better than what he
did yeah I mean it's lost position C4 is
not a good move okay C4 is not a good
move he should play Bishop D3
okay
this well it's a bad position but right
so it's not resignable
you take you take visibility because
because the other one is probably
something else it's like
for Bishop D5 Bishop oh Bishop takes F3
just yeah this is all yeah this is the
thing no no bc3 it's not over okay yeah
it's not over well I mean I mean the
source position but it's definitely a
playable this is what you think you
don't have to do right yeah create some
ideas yeah of course yes and then the
latest it was a moment when I uh and
they could probably
uh
sacrifice I could probably play E4
but I looked a little bit I didn't see
immediate win and it is dangerous to go
for position which is uh not winning and
then you think why did I do that and or
to spend too much time you know to make
so you have to play solidly It's Not
Practical yeah I mean you have porn up
you have a winning position you have two
Central points of course if it's if you
don't see immediate wind and then that's
a great lesson by the way yeah
never complicate when you don't have to
in a winning position if it's no problem
something like Nerf is low but not
Murphy's if it's no problem you don't
don't try don't try to solve problems
that don't exist very nice and he
resigned at this point Dimitri you've
been here in St Louis you've played in
St Louis how are you enjoying the
atmosphere seeing your old friends as
well playing chess uh you don't play
that much you're mostly a coach nowadays
yes yes my my best results from my
students
I was working with Victor course in the
80s and the 90s a little bit not but
then was a tremendously happy that it
happened in my life and it was his
results he's like he wanted his own
1980s
my student search Michael just got his
first GM normally very nice and of
course honestly it's a star star
students like a few years was great
she's amazing and I hope she'll go much
higher to become your champion and
whatever so you're seeing your friends
you're also seeing some of your students
here mostly yes my my friends many
people I know from the ages yes uh some
from the 90s Greek I don't know if I
know from the 70s so they all I enjoyed
to see them in the great great players
great people and that's that's very
enjoyable you know the Saint Louis is a
unique atmosphere of what we have here
great conditions and to see wonderful
people and great comments yes sir I'm
not playing
thank you for not playing that's a good
one
edema Kate has a question for you yeah
congratulations on your game today you
seem to be really enjoying you know
chess your games but you are also the
winner of the 2022 us singers Open
Championship so are you looking here to
to win the tournament not just enjoy the
atmosphere
she's saying that you want the U.S
Senior America
[Laughter]
excuse me
and also he bit Alex and he bit another
Alexa maninski so in five out of five I
made Wonder of his uh like fishbein and
then last round I just had to play for
me and I had no choice so I I tried and
at some point I was lost and I won that
was a miracle yeah and she's saying that
he won that one do you have Ambitions of
winning this Championship as well oh
what do you mean this this scene you're
open this one yes oh it's in European
yeah but it's going right now it's going
to be this weekend so I cannot play both
even if I had a rocket
no no but it was a miracle to it then
and I don't think it happened because
I'm senior but other seniors are like
Junior Jesse greyer in this one with
vladimiro copen I remember when he was a
teenager a teenager and now he's 50. he
looks still very young you know it looks
looks Junior
another miracle happened nice